le face à face avec marie elodie royer
bonsoir alors il est un peu difficile de
vous présenter déjà dire que vos
ateliers organise des portes ouvertes ce
dimanche est à voisins-le-bretonneux
mais lorsque je vous ai appelé pour
préparer cet entretien vous m'avez
expliqué pour résumer votre activité que
maud et compagnie c'est peut-être la
définition qui convenait le mieux vous
travailler dans la mode aussi bien en
temps couturière qu'en tant que soutien
pour ceux qui veulent se lancer pour des
projets vous m'avez dit je suis une
boîte à outils autour de la boîte et
parce que selon ce que les gens ont
besoin je m'adapte donc si on leur
demande donc ça peut très bien là en ce
moment je suis en train d'aider
quelqu'un pour relancer sa colère sa
collection de polos j'ai en même temps
je faisais développe un service de
retouche chez moi en même temps chez des
réalisations des créations et en même
temps je donne des cours de couture
l'activité principale ça serait quoi ce
serait la couture la mode
vous avez commencé il ya deux ans et
demi oui de zinc un voisin le booking
com comment est née cette commune et
cette aventure c'est que en fait j'étais
chercher un travail
et puis à ce moment là on m'a programme
j'avais un bâtiment qui était livre car
étant ma famille qui m'ont dit ça vient
va voir et je suis allé voir le bâtiment
plaisait bien cette semaine fait dans
cette ferme donc je me suis lancé et
donc je me suis dit c'est le moment ou
jamais pour se lancer parce que c'était
moment on envoie quelques images vous
vouliez véritablement un atelier par un
magasin il était guéri il fallait que
vous puissiez il travaille et il fallait
créer être à faire ce que j'avais envie
de faire comme je voulais le faire donc
quelle est votre formation comment on
apprend justement la mode dans les
grandes lignes alors moi j'ai fait des
études classiques j'ai fait un bep un
bac pro et un bts donc jusqu'au l'air la
couture scolaire donc voila et puis je
me suis lancé et ensuite vous maintenant
comment on fait on suit la mode au
quotidien on continue à se former aux
160 sultan tout le temps tout le temps
des gens
on fait des recherches quelqu'un qui
sait une certaine technique
on apprend en transe méfier ont professé
sur ses propres recherches puis en
développe ce que ce qu'on a envie de ce
qu'on aime plus faire que d'autres ce
que moi je suis dans le conceptuel que
que dans la fabrication donc j'ai plutôt
imaginer le vin produit que plutôt que
de l'eau coudre c'est la mode du moment
ce sera quoi la mode du moment sur quoi
fondez nous des indications qu'on puisse
tout de suite séparé alors moi je mets
ce que j'aime bien faire c'est les
salons donc voir les nouvelles tendances
pour l'année prochaine et couleurs me
renseigner un peu comment ça va être
plus tard donc en fait pour ça il
fallait dans des salons professionnels
donc mon les couleurs donc je peux pas
vous décrire les couleurs ce qui se
dénoue pas possible donc voilà mais
sinon ce que parce que ce que je veux
dire c'est ce qui serait plutôt tendance
tendance est ce qu'il faut avoir
obligatoirement pour cet automne hiver
2012 voilà qu'est ce que vous conseiller
médée de soi même voilà c'est un bon
conseil ça c'est qu'à toutes les saisons
et quels que soient les modes
effectivement ça c'est un bon conseil
vous donnez aussi des cours oui c'est
des conneries tu remets donc c'est des
cours donc chacun choisit ce qu'il veut
étudier selon ses envies selon quels
sont les types de demandes peut-être
travers qui reviennent le plus souvent
c'est très varié mais c'est très très
variés parce que ça va quel des gens qui
va apprendre à faire des vêtements pour
enfin de l'ameublement fait raster soi
même c'est pas trop ça change tout le
temps tout le temps il n'y a jamais la
même chose je sais jamais si ça change
alors pour ceux qui veulent découvrir
vos activités l'atelier
organise des portes ouvertes mais
ouverte ce sera ce dimanche oui c'est un
tout ça dès 18h comment ça va se
dérouler alors en fait c'est entre 10
heures et 18 heures donc en fait je fais
venir un négociant en tissus bénite ex
qui va proposer des tissus de haut de
gamme made in france
largement moins cher que d'autres
magasins 50% moins cher que d'autres
magasins
donc c'est un de mes fournisseurs que je
connais et je voulais proposer au grand
public pour la simple et bonne raison
que
je vois qu'il ya une demande crucial de
tissus actuellement dans la région donc
j'ai proposé de me propose à mon
fournisseur de bien finir pour cette
jambe donc elle demande mais ça coûte
cher c'est parce qu'il a beaucoup de
demandes que les prix montrent beaucoup
justement personnes disparaissent pu
faire rapidement les pour trouver du bon
matériel du bon tissu ça disparaît très
vite donc quand un bon finisseur en
garde
non justement dans un instant ce sera la
page économie de cette édition du 7 8
comment se porte votre activité s'en
remet à deux ans et demi à 12 ans et
demi belles séquences manquant le début
juin il faut se battre dans les clous un
petit peu de ce que vous aviez prévu où
ça reste difficile parce que je me dis
qu'ils ferment le tu sais que je suis
plutôt en train de me dire que je suis
content de ce que je fais je change j'ai
voulu j'ai voulu donc ça évolue donc
j'étais parti sur une idée ça évolue
donc je me laisse faire chier son gré du
vent
vous aimez votre métier vous le faites
partager avec ses ateliers ses portes
ouvertes également merci à marier le
livre y est elle est revenue sur ce
plateau nous parlions que seul atelier
de la londe 7 à voisins le bretonneux
portes ouvertes ce dimanche